à marseille également des centaines de
français étaient dans la rue cet après
midi une manifestation pour tester
toujours entre se passe sanitaires à les
manifestants présents sur le vieux port
de la cité phocéenne ont demandé
l'abrogation de cette mesure jugée
liberticide je vous propose d'en écouter
quelques-uns
ont le passé d'intrusion ça permet de
nous pister de savoir qu'on était tel
jour à telle heure et c'est peut-être
aussi à l'apprentissage et à la
soumission moi je crains que c'est
mettre un doigt dans un engrenage alors
si c'est un sujet politique qui
s'annonce vraiment
que c'est un sujet politique et après on
pourra discuter
politique ou sanitaire mais en ce moment
on mélange des deux donc ça c'est et
après on se demande pourquoi les gens se
posent des questions et quand les gens
se posent des questions veulent
s'informer on les traite de complotiste
moi je suis je suis pas rebelle fois
je pense ivax non plus
voilà juste le choix qu'on nous laisse
le choix ce que j'ai je pense que on est
de plus en plus contraints et là c'est
vraiment de contraintes
de plus ce qui fait que beaucoup de
monde est dans la rue